puis les élus locaux tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé dans un communiqué publié hier
la banco les territoires et
l'association des maires de france
inquiète pour la future santé financière
des communes du fait de la crise
sanitaire les collectivités locales ont
connu d'importantes pertes fiscales des
pertes que l'état ne compenserait pas
suffisamment à l'avenir résultat les
communes premiers investisseurs dans les
territoires réduirait à leurs dépenses
pour protéger leur épargne
écoutez à ce propos le secrétaire
général de l'amf ne voulons pas avoir le
choix entre garder un niveau
d'investissement important parce que
nous aurions une capacité
d'autofinancement importante qui nous
permettraient de recourir de manière
j'allais dire raisonnable un emprunt
voyez donc ce choix entre ça et le choix
entre justement la gestion de service
public et les dépenses qui contribue
donc justement au lien social
bon qui permettent donc d'organiser de
manière satisfaisante les écoles les
crèches les l'accueil des seniors et
tout ça enfin tout ce que nous faisons
la culture et c'est le sport voilà tout
ce qui est fait la vie locale
on ne veut pas avoir à faire un choix
entre rognés sûr c'est sur ces services
publics qui sont en france nous avait
une qualité et qui ont atteint dans
certaines collectivités un bon niveau
pas partout donc on voudrait continuer à
développer la qualité de ses services
publics et en même temps pouvoir
investir et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'action enfin la relation que
nous avons à l'heure actuelle avec le
gouvernement sur le plan financier n'est
pas satisfaisante parce que à l'heure
actuelle les collectivités locales ne
sont pas en position d'affirmer
premièrement je continuerai à rôle de
service public tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui
et deuxièmement je continuerai à croître
et même ma capacité d'investissement